good morning today is day number two of
this vlog
um as you guys saw yesterday tyka had
his second ever dentist appointment then
we got pizza then we played with grandpa
and today and then
yes he's correct it's
a weekend for him because it's spring
break um papa's currently in texas right
now he's gonna be in texas until monday
today's sunday so until tomorrow
um and then that whole week we don't
really have anything planned because
literally two months after
tyka is out on summer vacation so that's
when we booked a trip to hawaii so
yeah it's kind of gonna be business as
usual for us until tyka's out of school
in may
but that means he's just gonna be home a
lot so you see back here it says spring
break that whole like 10 days
yeah luckily we have grandpa living with
us now he's going to be living with us
until his house is finished getting
built out here in vegas he's been with
us i think now for about a week and it's
been kind of cool like we've been just
kind of like figuring out our workflow
um he has his routine we have our
routine and he just kind of jumps into
our routine
for now because i think he's just trying
to learn the landscape in terms of like
summerlin area
vegas area like henderson chinatown all
those little little pockets that he
would be um
uh living in so like yesterday when we
went to the dentist normally he'd be
like no no you guys just go but he was
like oh yeah i'll go i think he just
wanted to see what
dentistry out here looks like or maybe
if he wanted to
possibly go to that dentist office i'm
not sure it was just us three mitaika
and him he doesn't speak english i don't
speak chinese he's hard at hearing um
luckily i speak really really loud but
i don't know we made it work but yeah i
just wasn't sure why it was there anyway
i'm actually going to train
take my favorite pre-workout ever and
i'm not just saying that because it's
barbell brigade
i'm saying it because i'm so proud of
the formulation how well it works the
ingredients are just top tier we don't
use
any white label ingredients meaning like
they make
a
batch for literally
a general batch and then people just
come in and go yeah that's what i want
like ours is custom to our formulation
you're not gonna find anything on the
market like this and i'm just i get so
proud of it i'm always gonna promote it
because i think it's [ __ ]
but yeah today is uh bench day for me
i think my daily max is gonna be 95
pounds i forgot what that is in kilos
maybe 30 something kilos not sure
um
but yeah this thing is going to get me
through it
let's go
okay so now i'm at home goods
back there
but not like really at home goods
because they don't open till 10 and i
don't know why like so i okay i know why
i wake up heck early because
um
somebody doesn't like to sleep in ever
he's definitely a morning person um so
my day starts really early so when i
leave the house in my mind it's already
like after 10 because i'm like i've been
awake for hours already it has to be
like
after 10 o'clock
um
so
i leave the house thinking it's after
10.
like today for example i'm gonna go to
home the goods because i have to buy
like shower cars like there's
there's still a lot of things that i
have to buy for our house because i just
haven't had time to do
anything really to it like our interior
design stuff stopped because there's
just so many delays because of coved
shipment issues i'm like forget it
i'm not gonna like decorate anything or
do anything crazy
until like everything has opened up
fully who knows when that'll be i'm in
no rush to spend any more money really i
mean it's just a desire
this is what you're hearing take this
playing a game
okay so long story short which is still
kind of long story long is i left the
house thinking cool i'm gonna come to
home goods buy some shower curtains
good job
buy some shower curtains get a bunch of
like just little knickknacks that i need
need me like really neat around the
house
um i get here and it's only like 9 41
they open at 10 so yeah that's why we're
here in the car what's super cuny is you
can't see him now because it's empty but
grandpa is also with us which i'm really
surprised that he wanted to come with us
because bart right now is still in texas
um
yeah he's coming back on monday thank
you for the backup dude
um
yeah for the backup like you're giving
me you're like filling in the blanks for
me i like that
look
look at those balls
you poke my heart down
on my poop
who is this kid
but yeah we're just killing time right
now
[Music]
this car is honestly the ultimate family
car because like it has all sorts of
entertainment on it and i love it
and it drives itself so like if i need
to like if i might drop this i need this
we're like on the freeway then i can
just turn around and grab it for him
real quick
not the most safe but it drives itself
so we're okay
okay so there was success at
home beds i was gonna say home depot for
some reason i'm at this place called
tavoli village and they have like this
easter themed something
and
of course
of course has to be a monkey ready
oh i saw that okay this way come on this
way this way this way
it's really
it's really windy but yeah this is what
it looks like
it's really cool there it is tavoli yes
go
yeah
we have grandpa with us though
enjoying the little vegas
it's actually really
it's really nice and windy like it's
warm and it's like this comfortable wind
um
so this is it a bunch of arts and crafts
and stuff
super cool
oh
so we've made our first purchase here
okay taco what did you get what is this
dude what is that
you can make everything you want oh you
can make it whatever you want i love
that i have to put it with my
oh yeah it is like a really cool fidget
toy it looks like a snake a little bit
huh yeah but you still keep investing oh
okay
okay let's keep looking
so we came yeah what's up everyone so we
came here hold on one thing at a time
yes you got a spider but i'll explain
that a little bit so we got that at home
good then from home goods we went to the
tavoli village the way that i showed you
and it had a really cool like um littles
like farmer's market type deal but more
with like arts and crafts so like a
crafts market
um and in doing that grandpa didn't see
that there was a step and he fell and i
got really scared nothing happened to
him he just has a little scrape on his
knee but
i didn't want to walk around there
anymore so we just came back home he
says he's fine
so i don't know i'm going to monitor
that but
let me show you what we got
taka show me what you got
where did you get that from over there
that's not even yours
okay so what oh god this is so
disgusting you know he's family oh okay
fine all right so you're gonna put
batteries in it yeah so taika got this
from home goods oh this is so nasty no
he's he's my pet the other way yeah like
that you have to push it in and then
turn it then turn it push and turn
you're gonna help you
no i got it okay
okay i'll help you
oh my god i can't believe how much i
hate this
this is disgusting dude
yes it's gross
i hate it i hate it so much
no leave it leave it alone
go show grandpa go put it in grandpa's
room
go
where is he he's in the bathroom oh
i can just hear him laughing i don't
want to go in there if he's in the
bathroom oh god
i can't believe i bought that room it's
so nasty
how
if you ever were to ask me what's the
biggest purchase regret i've ever had in
my life
it's that thing it's disgusting
i heard it
okay so now let's talk about what i got
at home goods
and what i needed to go there sorry i
just went up the stairs
those things kick my ass every time okay
so some recent additions is we finally
added
and fought some light fixtures in all of
our rooms especially the ones that don't
have any candle lighting like taika's
gave him a new frame
let me show you this
taika's new bed frame the other one was
from ikea and it was like such a small
headboard that i always had to put like
a ton of pillows here because i was just
afraid he was gonna like lean back and
hit his head on the board so
this one is more appropriate way more
sturdy
it is a queen i didn't realize taka
didn't have
i didn't even know that this was a full
mattress so it is for queen frame but
for now
no one needs to know shh it's kind of
like that tick tock they're gonna know
they're not gonna know
they're gonna know
but
yeah
i stuffed this side
so his foot doesn't get caught in there
so that's
tyka's improvement we did this
added that so now he has some light in
here
and here is the other guest room
here
let me just open it
okay let me see okay
the other guest room i did buy another
headboard
not headboard what is it bed frame so i
need to fix that this is a queen size
mattress fix it so i got that
or i got this
for that which i just realized i didn't
need because i have everything here i
effed up
i might move that to tyka's room who
knows but
this is what i got
so i saw this and i thought it was so
cute but
it's ripped so i asked him to give me a
bigger discount instead of the 10 bucks
i think about it for like three bucks or
something this
because a headboard or bed frame is like
this rich blue
and then this to kind of offset the
color i just imagined it all in my brain
i don't know if it's gonna look really
good
and i like this because it was simple
white
and only 40 bucks and all the other ones
were 80
so it does have like a shell print on it
and it has all these other little extra
things that i could care less about so
i'm probably gonna give this to my mom
because she loves this thing
so give that and that to my mom
and then the rest i'll keep and i'll use
these pillows to kind of like make it
look a little bit younger and a little
bit more modern
again i don't know if it's gonna work
because i did just envision this all in
my brain
hence
the star to kind of like
tie it a little bit
i got
some neutral bed sheets
grandpa is fighting with taika
i got shower curtain
i think this one's for this room or
tigers i forgot
maybe maybe this one's for that room for
this one because the bed
frame is a little bit rich in color i
want it to kind of get something that
ties it all together
so i felt like this might work who knows
because right now i'll show you
this is what's in there now and it's
just
not about it we're just not about it
so
yeah gonna fix that
move this stuff out
i don't know we're moving slowly first
thing first though is
i gotta get that done
um
shower curtain and i got another shower
curtain because tyka doesn't have
the lining to it oh i should have got oh
no no i did this is for tyka's room
it kind of goes it's like a brown gray
little print on it very subtle but very
clean
so i'm gonna swap out what he has now
and then i got this
which is kind of expensive and it kind
of hurt a little bit so i hope it's
really good
uh it's a
duvet
i love it mine currently because i
refuse to get goose or feather down i
just feel like it's
so inhumane
even though i do consume meat and i do
consume dairy and i do
it's a battle in my brain too but as
much as i can cut out
animal products like even leather
if i if i don't have to have to use
leather i try not to so i try
i know i could do better but i really do
try to not
use or consume things
that come from animal one of them being
the goose down um
so yeah i get i always get alternative
uh
alt-down alternative when it comes to
like duvet and stuff and pillows and
[ __ ] like that
um so that's what i got there but
unfortunately the one i had
is that and after a while after you wash
it one second after you wash it it just
gets all clumpy okay let's see what
happens
so taika
and grandpa
are downstairs
watching spiderman
[Music]
while i'm up here
assembling this bed
and this is the blue i was talking about
it's this beautiful
like indigo or maybe like
i don't know what color would you call
this i think it's kind of indigo so i'm
actually thinking
that this is gonna look perfect
look at that
i pictured it good in my brains
yes i'm going to try to assemble this
hopefully i don't [ __ ] it up
shouldn't be too hard right this is the
headboard
oh well the other side of the headboard
all right let's see what happens
so taika is awake from his nap your
little cutie boy okay go see the the can
i take my spider yeah bring your spider
but wait just check out this the bed i
built
[Music]
just come up
okay okay let's go
okay bring your pet
oh yeah let me see it one more time so i
could remind myself how much i regret
this purchase ew okay these right here
let me see the things
they remind me of papa
dead one side i think there's one side
right
when he's not excited to see me mama
he's kissing
i know i'm wrong for that
i understand
but you know you laugh
okay go
mr
spider
we can take a walk let's go how about we
take him to the park sure bring him
we should bring him right yeah let's go
up yeah
go to the guest room
that way
[Music]
thanks dude
okay so let me tell you i was gonna use
are you listening to me good i was gonna
use the other one that i bought i'm just
kidding you don't have to listen to me
you though
please listen to me i was gonna use the
other one but the bed was already made
like this so i'm just gonna keep it
until we have to take pictures
but i don't really hate i don't hate it
i mean i don't love it look at my pen
but i don't hate it i have to add
something here i have to add something
there but hey guys look look at my pen
oh
no
and then i put this curtain up
it's more of a blue than a gray it shows
gray here but it's
like he's hungry definitely a blue
really look at look at what i put on
yours in your room
yeah i changed it because it was falling
apart
oh i didn't see it it's a shower curtain
it's your shop
yeah i had to put a new one up
that is
beautiful
you're so cute
okay
he's freaking cute but yeah super subtle
it looks very wrinkled but i mean the
more showers you take
it's like browns and then grays
it's super subtle
[Music]
okay now
where are we going
[Music]
okay got it
okay let's go to the park
mountains
[Music]
so
also decided to come out where's the
duty
yeah someone's playing baseball and it
like landed right next to us luckily it
didn't hit us i feel like it might hit
those houses
like back there
might hit the woods
oh i can't hit the wall because they're
not they're not
that they don't even break
yeah did you catch that because if you
didn't stream on you
okay
so we're at our favorite park right now
and this is so cool
okay i love it
i've never been to a park that looks
this peaceful
i hope it's not very windy huh
yeah i just don't know who it belongs to
dude
you want to ask them yeah okay let's go
ask them
what are you gonna say
nothing are you gonna say hey is this
your ball yeah okay
my son is the weird kid at the park
and now he's doing the girl the kid
monkey that is so i'm just getting a kid
funny
no
okay lesson learned there were like 20
million kids and they were gonna start
fighting over it new parent here so now
i know don't bring any [ __ ] pool toys
to the park or all the kids are gonna be
fighting for it brothers we're telling
on each other like i'm gonna tell on you
another kid's like why that's not even
your twitter can have a turn you have a
turn and then no one's like stepping on
it
lesson learned and now look what he's
doing
[Music]
just tumbling on the grass no toys
needed
see you later
[Music]
oh no he found the flowers
okay
so
there we go so tyke and i did something
on accident that was really cool ready
pretty good
dude
we made a beat let's see if we can do it
again
no no that's too good again again
whoa
so now tyke and i are playing what is
this called
jack slap jack and how do you play the
game um i mean if i swap out your head
at night and then shorts oh yeah and
tech is actually really good at this
game let's see if we see a slap jack so
they have different characters on it and
if you see a slap jack then you gotta
slap the deck like that and then whoever
slaps the deck wins and who won last
game
me i know you went all the time yeah i
think that but that but needs to be
white oh i see so i bought these games
for tycho maybe about like a year ago
from um target so if they come like in
like different ones it's that matching
one that i showed you there's this one
there's like a scavenger hunt one
there's like so many cool little uh card
games for them so
pick it up if you like not spawn but hit
me if you want to be spawn what hey hey
hey i did break dancing oh yeah you did
they saw look watch this okay watch it
whoa
he makes his own beat too okay so you
can't copyright us
oh don't say anything you'll get a
surprise don't say anything the universe
will give you a surprise
my mom would say that and then i was
like
i never got anything but it worked
because i was like i want something
monkey yeah i gotta have a new bracelet
no but show me these bracelets these are
special you know i made those yeah where
did you make them let me see that's cool
they're so cool can you tell me about
this one um i made this one and this one
had mid-ass sports a basketball soccer
ball baseball and poop and football
what's football okay what about this one
this one's beautiful um this one had
a
a fidget spinner a ball
it is a fidget spinner what about this
one this one's very unique
this one is clear
orange
black
green why'd you pick this one why'd you
pick these guys
got it and then what what about the
other ones
you didn't talk about these ones okay
well let's talk about that then
let's talk about it then what do you
want to talk about um about the police
with the other one yeah let's talk about
it oh this one has a star on it okay
let me count this
this one
there's a ball this one is a volunteer
there's another one and
this is a beautiful cup right here oh
yeah it's very beautiful good job
another baby blue waller
and then a big two big rollers
and then you should see that a pad a
black patties good job it's beautiful
and then and then a and then a roommate
and then another one
and then a wooly and then a ball and a
ball
beautiful and heart beautiful and a
fidget spinner and a ball
and a
star good job and what about this one
okay let's keep talking about it
we don't want to go
there
yeah we talked about that one we talked
about that one
and that one remember
and
one
yep no we did it yeah we did this one
yeah don't worry
okay let's talk about it okay well how
about this one yep we did it
no because i didn't did it okay let's
talk about it then and what about this
one yes we did no we didn't okay then
let's talk about it stop saying when i
i got confused they all look so
unique but similar and i got a new one
oh yeah
that's beautiful but do you talk about
this one nope
okay this one nope
come on nope let's talk about it
nope nope nope i don't think
this one nope
let's talk about this one okay let's
talk about it i made this one
um
no but really on that note thank you
guys so much for watching i will see you
guys